hey what's the funniest thing about
playing video games this one car start
okay
the funniest thing about video games is
very rarely what the creator's intended
usually the funniest thing is when the
game glitches out whether it's like
Minecraft or battlefield or like you
know army of two but it's it's hilarious
and we decided to make a video all about
here's the scoop let me fill you in
Jake is eating it some McDonald's
breakfast and when he's done we're gonna
move that truck over into that alley and
we're gonna unload like SWAT team style
and we're gonna get all our gear set up
and I'm gonna shoot this video in a heli
as per usual what's the plan for the day
aside from we're gonna shoot the video I
mean like I've been starting to use the
phrase like things are just glitching
out like when something goes wrong or
when someone like chokes or something on
food I'm like whoa dude you bitched out
we should just do a video where everyone
glitches out like in a video game so
that's kind of how the the video was
created
oh that's used to murder
I was looking at that TV for like 10
minutes and I was like I can't wait to
go over there and smash out of it oh my
god you guys probably noticed by now
that pretty much everything we shoot is
in an alley and the reason we do that is
because there's no one ever here like
look at this place
not only is it super gross and just
making people not want to hang out and
you buy it but it also blocks traffic so
we can come here shoot all day
we don't have cars coming in and out
yeah it makes it so we have a pretty
smooth shooting day uninterrupted one of
the two dirt roads in downtown LA that's
how deep in this we are this we're so
deep into this city
that's like we're like leaving it again
dude apparently we just found out that
in Brett's video the moustache was
upside down the entire time
my brother Joe got stolen no wow I don't
want it on yet I did I had it like this
did you yeah dude I had it curved I
wanted it curved I wanted like I wanted
the handlebar it was a Mario handlebar
cuz this I mean what kind of mustache is
this okay like they don't occurs at the
top comes up at the top I don't know the
sense in such that I thought that was
right that looks right I thought this is
this is how it works or that this is
right
did you make it do you make a good mark
I'm waking up to
right away
do
mmm-hmm hey what's going on over here
you don't this gun is stuck in the day
ground let us handle that don't even
crack it look at that I just broke the
plastic which means the front which ones
the back
yeah I was hoping that was the case I
think I'm probably going to shoot up the
live footage we need for my guy and then
I'm gonna save all the green screen
stuff for like last thing might not
actually shoot them today to make this
shot verse this is where the ground is
and just your legs are gonna be playing
and glitching out like put like this and
like the guns and then we're just gonna
take elements like this elements with
your like arms and the top half of your
body doing it and they're just going to
start mission mashing and combining
together for the actual final shot all
right so one of those common glitches
that you see is when somebody it's like
stuck in geometry and I start wiggling
around what we did is we had actually
film our you know a person or an arm or
whatever we need to do against a green
screen and had the person just wiggle it
and then we'd speed it up and the green
screen lets us take out the background
so you put the arm over any kind of
footage that you want dude when we're
composite put your head back I don't
want to see your face
[Laughter]
it's gonna break I wish you this is
gonna break this Justin Luigi has
disappeared with Yoshi we have no clue
where they are
Princess Peach has been reported sighted
with waluigi this past tuesday evening
at a Ruth's Chris Steakhouse they were
seen gallivanting and flirting all night
long one bystander said they looked
quite cozy we wanted to do a shot where
Nico unplugs the server of the world to
stop the glitch and Sam didn't want to
do it CG so we built the problem I built
the prop out of foam core I cut it up I
taped it together
most towards it
Jimmy man enough suicide you out
actually up cool yeah something like
that war so hope you guys like this
video and learn something from it if you
didn't know the volume up I'm gonna give
away some games on our Christmas we got
a whole bunch of steams dice the holiday
breaks are coming up for your respective
religions and you should check us out on
Twitter and on Facebook we have a whole
bunch of yeah we have a whole ton of
getting our gift accounts cuz he's just
been women wild during honesty every
single time there's a seam sale there's
we get a couple extra games just just
for you guys so anyways we're gonna be
giving away some sweet games in steam so
follow us on Twitter and maybe Facebook
if you want to copy a free copy of
Borderlands to subscribe to us on
Twitter because it's still sitting in my
steam gifts account you'll see you'll
see
you